[Music]
I've been following Jeff menos building
blog for I don't know as long as it's
been around as near as I could tell I
mean I'm an infrastructure nerd pretty
much every picture I take on vacation is
of sewer pipes and you know water
systems or all these kind of things I
always paying attention to
infrastructure and so the you know the
building block has been the place that
has turned me on to other things and
then and and really kind of let leapfrog
me around the internet around my
infrastructure obsession so when he came
out with this book around re looking at
architecture from the other users point
of view it really struck me and I had
recently taken a class on lock-picking
from someone who appears in the book or
at least credited in the book Eric and
when when I first picked when I picked
my very first lock it changed the way I
looked at the entire world and like
locks changed from a thing that were
this impenetrable barrier to it's just
it's it's a time equation and
fundamentally this book about a burglars
guide to the city is about changing the
way that a different perspective on the
city and I think I'm in there there's
the the one user group is of the
burglars in the 1990s in in LA there was
a burglary every 45 minutes of every
workday was that right so 1990s 45
minutes of every work day in LA there
was just in the LA area there was a bank
robbery going on so I mean it's like I
mean there's a whole population of
people that were that we're using
architecture and using the systems that
we had built in a very very different
way
and so you know with tools as simple as
as these that you can make at home all
of a sudden people could enter into
things most crimes or crimes of
opportunity but Jeff has really dove
into the parts of crime that were
pre-planned and that used architecture
almost as a weapon against itself and so
we're looking forward to this talk
welcome Jeff
enjoy well thank you thanks for having
me thanks for spending your Valentine's
Day evening talking about burglary and
bank crime and the long-term effects of
security architecture it's very romantic
thing to do it's nice to be back in San
Francisco as well my wife and I lived
here about 10 years ago and it's always
nice to come back and explore different
neighborhoods so it's good to be here
so as evander mentioned I'll basically
be talking about what are we looking at
here that's me okay so I'll basically be
just talking about some of the people
and stories from the book that I wrote a
brokerage guide that came out in the
middle of last year to really kind of
introduce many concepts about what
exactly is burglary what is its
relationship to architecture why would
someone who's interested in architecture
be interested in burglary you know
whether or not burglary is the same
thing as theft there are a lot of things
that we'll be talking about and looking
at but I wanted to just give a brief
note about you know exactly where I'm
coming from in this so as an
architecture and design writer you know
the thing that really struck out to me
about burglary and what drew me to it is
that burglary is it's very specifically
an architectural crime so burglary
cannot exist without the built
environment it's not the same thing as
theft in fact you can be a burglar for
your entire life and never steal
anything and you can also steal things
for your entire life
and not be a burglar so any felony or
the conspiracy or intention to commit
one inside an architectural space in
which you don't have permission to be
can be legally considered burglary and
so that has a lot of really interesting
and strange implications as I'll be
discussing over the next half hour or so
and those we can get into with questions
at the end
which which we I would encourage you to
have some of you I love talking about
this stuff but so I really wanted to
dive into that notion that burglary and
architecture were legally connected but
also very conceptually connected and so
the first thing I wanted to talk about
was is actually the title of the talk
was just the notion of breaking the
clothes and so what's fascinating about
burglary is that it even legally
redefines where architecture begins and
ends and so it may seem you know it's
even a kind of a I rollin joke in a lot
of architecture schools where you know
whether or not we truly understand the
difference between inside and outside
whether or not we actually can make that
distinction but what's interesting about
burglary is that it actually does call
that that distinction between inside and
outside into into into question and
that's this thing called the close which
is this invisible line wit that exists
surrounds objects and a kind of you know
I could I might describe it as a kind of
legal crystallography it's a series of
invisible planes that defines inside and
outside and so think about a couple
examples here would be think about a
convertible car parked on the street
with its top down think about a house
with a screened-in porch where there are
no screens on the installed on the porch
that on a particular day think about
your own home or apartment but the
windows are open or the front door is
open there may not physically be a
surface that that differentiates one
side from another the public world from
the private world but nonetheless there
is a legally recognizable surface called
the clothes and the clothes of course is
not clothing but the clothes is
enclosing a door or an enclosure that
that maintains that that that fiction of
inside and outside and so that might
necessarily might not necessarily sound
particularly interesting it's very
abstract but what's pretty shocking
about this actually is the extent to
which burglary can be attached to things
based on minuscule crossings of an
invisible barrier that basically only
lawyers can see so a good example of
that was a case where an individual came
up to a home and was threatening the
homeowner the threat in this case is a
felony and as the Senate individual did
so he leaned against the front of the
house there was a on the windowsill the
window was open and
tips of his fingers crossed the
invisible line from outside to inside in
tandem with threatening the homeowner
that was enough to get this guy nabbed
for burglary so the tips of his fingers
broke the clothes and that constituted
physical entrance into us into a space
you may recall actually an interesting
thing in New York City maybe three or
four years ago where as an art project
these two individuals replaced the
American flags with white flags like
surrender flags
it was interesting listening to the
police actually kind of you know grind
their teeth and fantasize about the
kinds of things they could charge these
guys with but one of them was burglary
well it's so interestingly enough it was
because of the fact that in order to get
to the top of the Brooklyn Bridge which
is obviously in 100% outside and any
layman's understanding of the Brooklyn
Bridge they had to go over a fence and
into a kind of fenced-in area that from
the point of view of the law could be
considered an internal space that they
broke into with the intention of
committing a crime of both vandalism and
trespassing and any other things they
wanted to throw and so that was an act
of burglary in plain air so you can
imagine in other words a whole series of
kind of malign architectural
interventions on private property here
in San Francisco or on corporate
property in a city like Manhattan where
small Incan almost imperceptible
additions to the facade of a building
could be used legally to entrap people
in burglary without realizing that
they've in fact stepped inside of
something so briefly again I just want
to mention that the other thing that
this does is that it also gives I kind
of compare to almost like an
augmentation spell so if you have done a
certain crime whether it's a violent
crime or a crime of drug possession or a
handgun or that kind of thing it's a
very good way to simply extend the
sentence that would otherwise have been
much shorter or to nab someone because
you couldn't get them for the crime they
were actually doing but you can get them
for burglary simply by dint of the fact
that it occurred within an architectural
space that they didn't have permission
to be in and so it's a very interesting
crime as its added on to things and has
that peculiar relationship to inside and
outside and so while kind of diving into
the rabbit hole I guess you could say of
burglary and its relationship to
architecture you can see that you know
over centuries in fact the way
that burglars look at the built
environment has been treated almost
almost like semi mystical terms while
the infographic that you're looking at
which is about a century old doesn't
necessarily have a tone of mysticism to
it what I think is so interesting about
this is that the implication of an
infographic like this is that burglars
are looking at buildings differently
that they are getting into your house
and physical ways that you yourself have
not anticipated that they have figured
out a way to solve the puzzle of
architecture that wasn't available to
you or to other homeowners and that they
have a way of getting inside buildings
that you might in fact need an
explanatory infographic to explain and
so I really like this notion that
burglars have figured out something
about cities or the built environment
that that is not common knowledge and
that in fact needs this level of
explanation and so in diving into how
other how people use architecture I got
really fascinated by the fact that you
know it's easy to take for granted that
you're supposed to use doors to get from
one room to the next you're supposed to
go down a corridor to make it through a
building you're meant to use the streets
outside to get from one building to the
next but burglars find a way of
deliberately avoiding doors they'll cut
a hole through a wall
they might even avoid the wall and cut a
hole through the floor or the ceiling
they might avoid floors and ceilings and
cut through roofs or come up from the
sewer network beneath the city in an
example that I'll come back to in in in
a few minutes but so this relationship
to architecture is one in which I
suppose you could describe it almost as
a kind of topological relationship in
that it's a more engaged
three-dimensional interaction with
architectural space than the ones that
we limit ourselves or I'll speak for
myself the one that I limit myself to as
a law abiding user of architecture
you know I follow what the architects
laid out for me by going through doors
I don't crawl through windows very often
and I tend not to use a concrete coring
machine to get to the next floor but
this is something that burglars will do
so a couple just quick examples that I
go into more length in the book you know
this can be either an ingenious act of
almost revelatory architectural
short-circuiting such as a guy this an
individual named Bill Mason who at one
point was robbing a mob connected hotel
outside Cleveland which sounds like a
good idea
he wanted to get into the cash room but
it was heavily guarded so he had to rip
the realization that the way the hotel
was built he can in fact just break into
the hotel room next to the office go
into the closet cut a hole through the
drywall no one you know they're not
protecting the walls from within go into
the cash room steal whatever he wanted
to and then leave out of a door of his
own making as he referred to it like a
kind of pop-up entry way through through
the world of architecture those examples
are obviously uh there are many examples
like that in the in the world of
architecture as the book goes into or
the world of burglary but then on the
flip side of that there are people who
in trying to second-guess architecture
it doesn't go quite as well so one
example was a this this kid who I still
kind of feel bad for but in the City of
Milwaukee Wisconsin decided in the
middle of the night to break into a
veterinarian's office but instead of
going through the front door which would
have been too easy or even going through
the window which made too much sense he
went up to the roof cut a hole into the
HVAC system and then proceeded to remove
all of his clothing I think under the
impression that that would reduce
friction and slip into the
air-conditioning duct in order to get
some painkillers down below but in this
kind of you know in the book I compared
to a surreal nudists remake of die hard
and in his nudity he get got trapped
away was he had a flashlight in one hand
and a hammer in the other and in trying
to get out of the air duct I was making
so much noise that when the people
showed up six or seven hours later they
actually thought an animal had been
trapped inside the air duct and he had
to be removed by the fire department but
so those kinds of examples are pretty
shockingly common you find that burglars
and trying to rethink the notion of a
get away there's one great example in
New Zealand where somebody broke into a
house and then it tried to get away by
actually going further into the house so
he crawled up into the ceiling and then
somewhat incredibly his toe was sticking
out of the ceiling insulation and the
police spotted this body part from
nowhere coming down from the ceiling
tiles and pulled him down and arrested
him there are a lot of examples of
people trying to hide inside walls to
get away
to cut their way deeper and deeper into
buildings and have to call the call
9-1-1 themselves in order to get out so
what I'm getting at is that for every
intelligent or exciting misuse of
architecture there are these weird sort
of dead-end misuses of architecture that
don't quite go as planned but so what
else I like about that image is that you
know you and you see this even in police
reports where when someone breaks into a
building and these are just kind of eye
candy images in the background but when
you see someone break in you know first
you see an arm come through a pet door
or you see a leg come through the cash
deposit chute or you see a head pop out
of an HVAC system or you see someone's
toe sticking out of this the ceiling
insulation burglars have this very
peculiar relationship to the in built
environment in that they are almost
passing through it like ghosts or I
sometimes compare it to the creatures in
Edwin Abbott's book flatland which are
these higher dimensional objects moving
through ours and they are seen according
to shapes that we can recognize there
are these ghostly body parts that it
sort of appear in our world but they're
not supernatural they're burglars and so
it really became interesting to me as
again someone who writes about
architecture and design that these
people exist out there that they are
thinking so differently about how to get
from one room to the next or one
building to the next that they will
repurpose tools that are used for
working on automobiles or demolishing
buildings and put that use those as
almost skeleton keys to get to get
inside of buildings and we'll return to
some of these questions of tools later
on this evening but what I wanted to do
is focus on an example to hopefully
ground some of this but also show the
the true creativity that I think exists
amongst burglars and also a relatively I
I hope is a good example for many people
in the audience here which is an
individual named Jack Jackson who got in
touch with me actually through having
heard through word of mouth from some
friends of his in the security field
that I was writing on a book writing a
book about burglary so his name is not
jack taxman it was a pseudonym and he
actually works now in the security
industry and his current employer
doesn't know that he used to be a
burglar or used to be a burglar
it wasn't immediately clear from the
conversation that he had actually given
given up
he was pretty pretty enthusiastic about
the things he was talking about but so
among many many things that he discussed
that all of which you know would I could
go into great length about there were
two things I wanted to discuss one was
that his relationship to architecture
was so granular and specific that in
order to you know break into whether it
was a high-rise apartment or an office
building at Toronto he would actually go
through jump through a lot of Hoops to
get a hold of construction information
so he would do things as as simple as go
to online resources for the construction
industry to try to find exactly what had
been used in the construction of a
building so that he could know what the
walls were made out of so he could bring
the appropriate tools or even know how
loud it was going to be as he cut from
one room to the next what people hear
him doing it
what grade of concrete was it maybe it
was only drywall etc etc he would go to
the point of actually formed he formed a
fake legal company with a business card
and would pretend to be involved in
lawsuits in order to get floor plans of
buildings that he claimed to have an
apartment in where there had been a leak
but the example I want to focus on this
evening is that and again these are fire
insurance Maps they're just eye candy
they actually are not directly relevant
to what I'm about to discuss but they
are thematically relevant and also quite
nice to look at but so was that the fire
code of Toronto you know which of course
exists to protect you and I to protect
the people who live there to make sure
that you don't die in an inferno that
you can get out of a building safely and
that the fire crews can find you there's
there are other ways of looking at that
fire code and so for Jack decks when
what he had realized was that if you
take it at its word and you realize that
the fire code of Toronto is so detailed
and so rigorously applied across the
city by memorizing it and understanding
exactly what it demanded of the built
world he was able to determine from the
outside of a building that he had never
set foot in really really detailed and
accurate estimates of the layout of the
building without ever setting foot
inside of it so things like the distance
between the door of an apartment to the
fire escapes that are this using the
emergency fire stairs that might exist
inside is mandated by law and so they
or you can start piecing together the
floor plan for for individual floors and
choose which apartment you might want to
rob the note the floor that would have
an alarmed fire escape door inside so
that he would deliberately choose the
ones that weren't alarmed so that if you
had to flee aDNA at a moment's notice he
could take that door and leave there's
something really fascinating I think
about this notion that the literal code
of the city you know this otherwise
extremely dry thing that again to speak
for myself I spend zero time thinking
about can in fact become this really
sophisticated targeting mechanism for
somebody with nefarious goals in mind is
something that I think is a great
example of the kind of dual use that
burglars put the the built environment
to including some some things that will
look out later but I love this notion
that this thing built to protect us to
help the city be designed in a way that
benefits all of us can in the rights or
perhaps the wrong hands turn into
something that endangers everyone and
allows people to choose the the
buildings that they might break into
without any kind of hands-on knowledge
of that but so that notion of misuse is
something that we'll see a lot you know
was actually just funny Xander was
showing the the lock-picking tools a
couple minutes ago and when I was
studying lock-picking as well while
writing the book it was really
interesting to hear about some of the
tensioning tools and some of the things
that you use to pick padlocks and and
and door locks and whatnot actually have
very mundane origins that were
surprising to me so one for example are
the street cleaning bristles on on
trucks the ones they zoom down the
street and just basically put all of the
debris into the air and when those when
those bristles come off you know there
are a lock-picking crews who kind of
religiously follow these street cleaning
trucks around to pick up the the the the
metallic bristles and turn them into
tensioning tools or even the under wires
and women's bras are apparently ideally
suited for bending and then using to
insert into padlocks but I love this
notion that we are first of all that
there are kind of skeleton keys hiding
in plain sight that it's up to us to
assemble but that also that through the
clever misuse of the built-in bar the
everyday environment we can find access
to parts of the world that are not
intended for us so now let's say
you can take that an insight of Jack Dax
Minh and the fire code you know what
else could be done with that sort of
thing so now to scale that up to an
almost delirious extent and now imagine
instead of the fire code it's the actual
storm water network for the entire city
of Los Angeles again Xander mentioned
some of this in the in the beginning but
Los Angeles is a really interesting test
case it's a kind of Coliseum of Bank
crime in the late 1980s and 90s it was
enter mention was the was the bank
robbery capital of the world there was
that that statistic of a bank robbery
every 45 minutes of every workday is not
only accurate but is mind-boggling
that's so many banks being robbed and
one of the there are many many factors
into what went into this rash of bank
crime in Los Angeles in the in the era
but one of the explanations and
something I think is quite interesting
in terms of misuse is that there was
this phenomenon known as a stop and rob
and so a stop and rob is a financial
institution a bank a credit union that
kind of thing that's built at the bottom
of an off-ramp and at the bottom of an
on-ramp so you can stop and rob get back
on the freeway and and you know be in
Burbank and 20 minutes later traffic
depending but so the notion then of
course the transportation engineers in
the 1960s we're building freeways they
were being celebrated by architectural
writers like Reiner banham as this new
sort of vernacular experience of space
and the City of LA but in fact they're
driving over a kind of three dimensional
Bank crime tool a burglary tool that was
the size and shape of the city's freeway
system I think that kind of thing is
quite fascinating and now of course
that's the freeways but now let's go
under the surface of the earth into the
storm water networks so at the height of
all this Bank crime in 1986 and this is
one of my favorite stories in the book
there's a nod there was a still unsolved
crime that became known as the hole in
the ground gang and so there's a bank
that you can I think one of these
there's a laser pointer somewhere here
but so in this map actually okay this
isn't gonna work so if you look to the
right that's actually looking north and
so those are the Hollywood Hills
draining south down into the city and
amidst all of that at the corner of
sunset and Spaulding there
a bank it's now a talent agency but over
the course of May and June of 1986 the
bank employees began to notice all these
strange things occurring they started
noticing weird electrical effects the
telephone systems were short in and out
the lights would turn on and off the
music would turn on early odd moments
they'd hear sounds that would then go
away they would call the police and say
there's something happening in the bank
because you please come sort it out but
they would inspect the vaults alarms
would go off but nothing was happening
there's no one in the vault there's no
evidence of tampering and so the police
dismissed it as a large rat but the bank
employees began to think of it as a
poltergeist which i think is interesting
for at least two reasons one with which
is that it was still only two or three
years after the movie poltergeist came
out but also I love the fact that it was
it seemed more believable to them that
the bank would be haunted by the
supernatural figure then that there
might be burglars trying to get in from
below which touches back again again on
that notion that burglars are almost
these supernatural presences in the in
the in the built environment so what was
actually happening was that a crew of
individuals who are assumed in
retrospect to have made men burglary and
bank crime is a relatively not
universally but relatively firmly
gendered undertaking but the their
knowledge of the storm sewer network by
following the old streams that came down
all the Hollywood Hills that would then
drain down through the old valleys of
Los Angeles there now they've now been
converted and canalized and turned into
the tunnel networks that extend for
miles and miles in this labyrinth
beneath the city eventually go all the
way down in this case to Bayona Creek
and then by Yona Creek then drains down
and so they are seated at Pacific Ocean
they knew this is the series of storms
who were so well and you can see in
these in these really beautiful
schematic diagrams that are available on
the internet if you if you have
nefarious things in mind but uh they
knew it so well that one of the FBI
theories actually was that the the team
might have been disgruntled Water and
Power employees that their knowledge of
the city was such that they would just
decided to to put it to more lucrative
use so to speak and take advantage of
the fact that they knew that a in Los
Angeles a is
acted to be through this sort of
filigree of tunnels that we don't see or
even necessarily think about and that if
you control the the sewers you can
effectively get you can control the
banks from below so what was happening
was that they were driving a group of
suzuki four-wheelers which are really no
narrower than the actual tunnels
themselves so you've got these
individuals hunched over suzuki
four-wheelers driving into the darkness
of los angeles night after night after
night for i think it was about three or
four weeks while they were building a
side tunnel and so you can see in this
photograph which is actually a
photograph of a photograph which was
shown to me by retired FBI agent named
william j Rader who's a really great guy
who I really enjoyed meeting but also
his his claim to fame sorry was that he
was he was he was the guy who was
shattered by Keanu Reeves when they made
the movie Point Break and so Keanu
Reeves and Bill Rader spent a couple
weeks together fighting crime in Los
Angeles but Bill memorably pointed out
that Keanu never asked any questions and
none of the things that bill writer told
him about fighting bank crime made it
into the movie Point Break yeah it's a
it's not nominative determinism that
work but so so Rader met with actually
my wife and I at a at a cafe near the
Santa Monica Airport which is also
interesting cuz that's there's a scene
in Point Break set at the Santa Monica
Airport but in any case he had these
files and these photographs and so what
these guys have been doing it they they
they drove into and they kind of set up
a drilling camp underneath the surface
of Los Angeles and they began tunneling
a block about a block and a half two
blocks east to go underneath this Bank
and so they were very very good at
tunneling and so the second theory that
the FBI came up with was that they were
so good at tunneling that they might
actually have been disgruntled mining
engineers and so they had you know come
down from the mountains of the Sierra
you know with this sort of
battle-hardened vision of the earth's
sub-surface
and they decided to put that to use
digging tunnels and robbing banks so it
was a very very good tunnel they didn't
use any reinforcements and in fact it
was quite a clever design they had
some improvisational hydrological
engineering as well because in order to
get rid of all that debris which is an
awful lot of you know excess rock and
sand and that kind of thing they would
build up a little dam inside the storm
water sewer Network excuse me so that as
even a trickle of water came down the
Hollywood Hills that would build up you
know inch by inch by inch and form a
small reservoir under the city that
they've and then knock out all of that
water would then flow through the tunnel
it would wash away all the debris would
wash away their footprints it would wash
away sticks of gum DNA evidence whatever
it is that they might might otherwise
have had and kind of clean the the crime
scene afresh every few nights the other
really clever thing that we're doing
however was that they were attaching
their industrial tools to the bank's own
electrical network and so like a kind of
electrical jellyfish they were tapping
up into the dangling wires and cables
that controlled the bank which is of
course in retrospect that makes sense of
why the bank employees were hearing
music at nine o'clock at night why the
telephones are shorting out it was not a
poltergeist it was the bank people spa
or the the the hole in the ground gang
splicing in from below but so once they
actually got into the bank you know they
they they they chose a three-day weekend
which is kind of a cliche of heist films
but is actually a great time to break
into banks you have more time they had
set off the alarm so many times that the
police didn't take it seriously so even
though they set off the vault alarm and
the bank alarm was going off most of the
weekend nobody came I was just there was
that Bank up on sunset again it was the
bank that cried wolf and so they had
three entire days here's their actual
tunnel it almost looks like something
out of Cappadocia and and I got away
with it so I could go it into this at
much greater length that I'll mention
briefly that they came back a year later
and this is the even these crimes are
still unsolved they came back in the
summer of 1987 and they started
tunneling into a bank if you know la at
the corner of Pico and La Cienega and so
they got even better at tunneling in
this case and so they didn't set off any
alarms and so of course their expertise
there that they had met were now
applying worked against them because now
finally when they did get into the vault
they set off the vault alarm and the
police immediately swarmed the bank
so as the bank was you know being locked
down from above they were fleeing below
they crawled back into their tunnels
they got back on those zukie
four-wheelers and they fled off into the
darkness
what's pretty incredible is that their
getaway route was an entirely
subterranean journey beneath the streets
of Los Angeles of multiple miles they
ended up getting down all the way to the
Bayona Creek where they abandoned their
Suzuki four-wheelers but again that
knowledge of the city the fact that they
didn't take any wrong turns they didn't
get lost they didn't choose the tunnel
that was ever narrowing they didn't hit
it great or not a great excuse me a
gates that had been locked to prevent
them from passing they clearly knew what
they were doing they had a knowledge of
the city like jackbacks ones knowledge
of the fire code of Toronto and they
were able to get away Bill radar joked
that if it's now beyond the statute of
limitations and so even if they were to
show up at LAPD headquarters or the FBI
LA headquarters tomorrow and say this is
how he did it these are the photographs
of us doing it this is us spending the
money they could they couldn't be
arrested all they could do is buy them a
stake in a martini there are many more
things to that I could discuss there but
I want to continue down this track of
what it means to be speaking with the
FBI and with law enforcement about
burglary
it was Corso it was a rhetorically
interesting to figure out how to do that
while researching a book about burglary
you know telling the police and in a
enthusiastic manner that I wanted to
learn how to get away from police
helicopters or you know what what what
might make a perfect bank run was
something I quickly learned to phrase
those questions and statements
differently but what was fascinating
about speaking with the FBI in
particular was that these tools in the
same way that you can take something
from one field like a street cleaning
Bristol and turn it into a lockpick you
can take something like fire code and
turn it into a targeting mechanism you
can take burglary itself and turn it
into a method that law enforcement will
use and so the FBI actually are one of
many federal agencies that have have
over time basically turned into burglars
extraordinaire in order to get a like oh
and these are files in fact that have
been foiled and are available on the FBI
website from a group that they call
surreptitious entries or their tactical
operation squad and so these are deep
well
I shouldn't say detail they're heavily
redacted files of different operations
to put mics and surveillance equipment
inside the homes or offices of people
connected to the mob or of drug
traffickers or of other people that the
FBI might be targeting including
political dissidents and figuring out
ways to get into buildings so all
they're just two things I want to
mention here there are obviously things
that we could discuss in terms of the
politics of this what it means to have
federal burglary crews that work but I
want to just mention two quick things in
terms of the types of what they use for
these kinds of things so there's a group
that was referred to as Operation
stagehand which is a pretty accurate
name for what they got up to but in
order to disguise the federal breaking
and entering they would do everything
from travel with vials and bags of dust
so that if they went into let's say a
mob boss's home and they put a wiretap
there another wiretap at a microphone in
the in a light fixture and then they act
inadvertently brushed some dusts off of
a lampshade or off of the top of a
stereo they would then take out their
vial of dust and almost like a kind of
Harry Potter figure they would just
sprinkle dust on whatever they had left
behind
they even had an example that I think
was great which was that they'll
disguise one another's activities so
that you can someone else can break into
a building while everyone else is kind
of running you know camouflage out on
the street and so they actually had
pop-up shrubbery that were attached to
umbrella opening mechanisms and so
someone could sit down and lockpick
their way into a warehouse well
miraculously a whole series of plants
would just appear which were these
pop-up umbrella based artificial
shrubbery that would be used to disguise
the FBI's undertakings in any case
following on this this train of thought
the when I went into this I was thinking
things like lock-picking
that there was a very subtle approach to
the tools of breaking and entering and
that there was a kind of way to finesse
your way into architecture that there
was a almost this this
and held artists artisanal beauty of
getting into locked spaces what's
interesting about burglary and about
breaking and entering and about forced
entry is that in fact the true tools of
burglary of super burglary that that an
evenly even with the hole in the ground
gang used to get into the bank itself
they used a concrete coring machine that
you would use in construction demolition
and and yeah and sewer work these tools
do exist but they're under the
controlled use of law enforcement
agencies and so and firefighting
personnel and that kind of thing and so
what really began to intrigue me in that
I this was another rabbit hole that I
went in down while writing the book was
that exploring that where these things
are who operates them and who has access
to them was something that was really
fascinating so you've got things like
fire departments with the torches to
burn their way into buildings or axes to
cut through you know walls that you
would think would otherwise keep anybody
out
you've got pneumatic door spreaders that
like the jaws of life that would be used
to rescue from a car accident but yet
can be used to spread the door jamb of a
house so that you can no longer
physically close the door
and I was able to spend a day with an
ATF agent Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms
these are not my photograph but learning
about the kinds of things that the ATF
used to get into buildings and with
rapid entry teams and so one of the
great tools here is the burning bar you
can see this being used you can use it
to take apart entire pieces of
industrial infrastructure it was
actually invented to help dismantle war
material after World War one so when
you've got fields and fields full of
destroyed tanks in order to take them
apart you've got this tool that burns so
hot it can melt granite and now of
course you can use it to get into bank
vaults or to get through doors and locks
of any kind but what was really
interesting was learning especially from
an architectural point of view was that
they they have this thing and he he
referred to it as door school which I
thought was a great description but so
it looks almost like a kind of
avant-garde art installation because
when you see door school it is literally
just doors in the middle of nowhere so
you have a meadow and they'll be six
doors next to one another or it'll look
like a basketball court and they'll be a
bunch of doors in it like these TARDIS
like structures but then the teams will
line up and they'll practice ways of
breaching is what is what the term is
and the ways of forcing their way
through these different doors using
different technologies but even here
though you see these really great
examples of memory use technology from
other fields so a couple examples that I
really thought were interesting or that
IV bags filled with water water cannot
compress and so if you drive an
explosion explosion or a forced through
water it'll amplify the explosion so
just detonation cord and IV bags filled
with water lined up on a door will
amplify the detonation cord enough that
you can blow the door off of its hinges
effectively without using explosives
another example are actually air bags
that you would have in a vehicle have
been repurposed so that you can attach
air bags to doors and basically blow
them off the hinges it's in order to get
in inside there's one example that I'm
tracking down that I'm excited to learn
more about but was a series of cash
deposit robberies and Scandinavia using
potatoes so potatoes of course are and
this is not the actual to statistic but
they are let's say 85% water I please
don't quote me on that but there's their
high percentage of water which means
that they are an ideal explosive
amplifier and so if you fill up in a
cash deposit box with potatoes but you
need to blow from the inside out without
destroying everything else you can then
drop those relatively small explosion
then explosive in it'll be amplified by
the potatoes and will blow the door off
the hinge from the inside out
so whoever figured that out you know
deserve some sort of potato metal but
it's that kind of creativity and that
kind of misuse of everyday objects that
I think is both interesting but also
points out the fact that the only thing
keeping people out of your residence is
the moral code of not entering and the
legal punishment of whether or not they
do so it's physically possible to do
this you know the military has ways to
get into basically any type of structure
in the world whether it's a nuclear
power plant a bank vault or obviously
your own home I think it's quite
sobering to realize that the tools exist
to get into anything and that your
protection is entirely dependent on
following codes of recognition about
where personal or private space begins
and where the world of other people ends
but the final thing I want to talk about
then is that if all of these tools are
being developed if things like burning
bars exist if things like the jaws of
life are now being applied to
architecture as opposed to car accidents
it seems like only a matter of time
before somebody would build architecture
to resist these tools and so I found
myself actually speaking with this
individual named Carl al-assad and so
Carl was a really fascinating individual
he owns a place called business called
city safe it's in a warehouse in rural
New Jersey it's about an hour and a half
south of Manhattan and as you pull up to
this place it was quite funny that there
was a ruin safe out in the front yard
almost as a reminder either to himself
or to other people that basically
everything can be broken into or
violated but so Carl was a retired New
Jersey State Police officer who while
working as a cop was really struck by
the emotional impact of burglary
something that prior to now I have not
mentioned but for him seeing what
happens to people after they've been
burglarized after someone has violated
their sense of space and security when
somebody comes in and whether they
whether or not they steal something of
value to them or simply break and enter
and and reveal that somebody has been
inside their their their house was so
emotionally traumatic that it was
something that he effectively wanted to
devote the rest of his life to to
finding a way to create an absolutely
impermeable barrier to make sure that
Breaking and Entering could in fact
physically be stopped and so while
working with he's also an insurance
investigator for Lloyds of London so the
warehouse you get you can only make out
the you can't really see this actually
in the background here but I'm behind
that curtain in that you can see in the
photograph one of the things that was
fascinating about this place was that he
gets shipped pieces of safes but also
whole chunks of wall that have been cut
through at say like gold depositories or
banks or even private homes so if you're
familiar with the work of Gordon
matta-clark the American artist the the
entire warehouse had the strange feeling
of being in a Gordon matta-clark
installation in that there were
fragments of walls with holes cut
through them there were pieces of
objects that may cut in half and never
they're on display almost as the
forensic evidence of crimes that had
happened in the past but so Carl got
really obsessed with this and he started
experimenting with a whole range of
things including a proprietary concrete
mix that that he wouldn't go into the
the ingredients of when speaking with me
and a series of bolt together modular
panels they're about two feet by two
feet and can be built up to any size as
you'll see in a one of the forthcoming
slides so this is the interior view or
can only be bolted from the inside but
so what Carl's calculation was at the
time was really interesting in in the
early 2000s in particular the the bad
guy so to speak the tools that he was
protecting against were tools that were
the discarded military remnants of the
former Soviet Union and so you've got
Kalashnikovs ak-47s you've got Russian
rocker propelled grenades you've got all
kinds of Russian military weaponry that
flooded the market after the Soviet
Union fell apart and those were the the
the tools that ended up in the hands of
the terrorists armies criminal gangs and
the kinds of things that were being
confronted in Karl's imagination at
least by the people who might want to to
purchase a safe room or panic room which
is what this which is what the the
structure is that you're looking at it
is really interesting just to point out
that it that calculation is different
now especially after the debacle of the
US occupation in Iraq
it is now u.s. weaponry that has flooded
so many of these overseas places where
we are now and you could argue that
carl's things are protecting against the
wrong weapons now but so he's ethnically
Russian and he would actually ship these
these panels all over to a Russian air
base where they would be tested against
Kalashnikovs against 50 caliber sniper
rifles against rocket-propelled grenades
and and I love the example as well of
even of c-4 explosives which are the
same kind of things that you would use
to bring down skyscrapers and sports
stadiums but even those can't take apart
the panic rooms
of Carl al-assad and so I really like
this notion that in and these are the
kind of configurations that they can be
built into but that someone would have
such a moral repugnance at the
possibility of burglary and at the
notion of trying to keep people from one
space out of the next out of the next
room adjacent to it that Carl has
effectively inadvertently created this
architecture that will outlast
everything you know that as you know
skyscrapers will fall the banks of the
world will crumble to dust the pyramids
will long since have been eroded but
there will be these undeniable panic
rooms how housed or you know we've
filled with the skeletons of the
ultra-rich lasting well into the the
distant future so I love the notion that
human security in this case then the the
quest to prevent burglary could actually
be the last thing that survives of human
civilization on earth and in fact
actually the thing that otto was drawing
was one of the patent diagrams for carl
when he figured out how to make the the
panelized panic room and so this thing
you can bolt it together into just as
safe as you can see here or you can
literally as if playing Minecraft you
can make this thing there's there's no
you know if you're a billionaire there's
no limit to what you could actually
build with these things you can go as
high as you want as long as you want and
you can build just these these infinite
labyrinths of fortification I think I'm
actually gonna leave it at that
with those stories and then I'd love to
if there are questions to talk about any
other aspects of burglary whether its
technical moral legal or architectural
but thank you
[Applause]
thank you there's gonna be a mic going
around so and Michael has it so I'll
I'll take the liberty of the first
question but if you do have a question
raise your hand and and I know Mike will
get to you and that way the people
listening on the livestream and our
video will actually hear those questions
so I mean the the most fascinating thing
to me about infrastructure is it's kind
of the longest thing that humans do in
the built environment that that you know
the sewage system the electrical system
underneath that the building's that we
live in are often thought of as at least
century-long investments by the people
who are building them but it was it's
the burglars that are looking at them
from a whole different point of view and
this point of view of fundamentally of
time and then and there's two sides of
the time right there was the time of how
long it takes to get in and then there
was the question of whether or not they
could get out and I you you open the
book with a great story of the the
Leslie gang and and one of their crimes
and particularly what they did to the
night watchman which I thought you might
actually recall here yeah really quick
background that yeah the the book opens
with the story of a man named George
Leonidas Leslie who for me at least
really sums up the relationship between
burglary and architecture he was trained
as an architect he moved to New York
City in the 1860s
so immediately following the Civil War
it was a really great time to be an
architect in New York in fact it was the
beginning of the Gilded Age Superman
shion's we're popping up on along Fifth
Avenue financial institutions were
moving to the city you know he and he
was a pretty talented individual but
instead of hopping a board and designing
you know the next Art Museum of for New
York he decided to use his architectural
skills to become the the most prolific
bank robber of the 19th century his gang
was was behind 80 percent 8 0 % of all
the bank crime in the United States at
the time but so he would do things like
build duplicate vaults he would do the
kinds of things that have now become
Hollywood cliches so he would use his
photographic memory to remember the
layout of vaults and then he would build
them again in a series of warehouses
over in Brooklyn
so that his crew could then train on
these surrogates and get it down to the
point where they could actually turn out
the lights and they could do it in the
dark without even bumping into chairs
and that kind of thing
so they would practice on a microcosm of
the thing that they were about to
assault but so their cleverness didn't
extend just to architecture they did at
least two things I'll mention one was
that they broke into the Metropolitan
Opera and they still hold costumes and
so they would you they used costumes and
opera props to as part of their way of
hiding their bank runs and so they would
unfold like us the the screen that would
hide an actor who's awaiting his or her
cue to go on stage they would use that
to hide lock-picking operations that
kind of thing but then at one point they
actually were in a town I believe this
was in min Massachusetts but they went
in and they went to the night watchman's
house they tied up the entire family and
then the the detail was that they then
went around in the house and they
stopped all of the clocks and so they
did that so that when the night what the
they would have no idea how long they'd
been tied up they wouldn't be able to
give the police any sense of oh they
left three hours ago or four hours ago
or 15 minutes ago obviously they could
have counted the entire time but
something tells me that the panic would
have would have prevented that but I
loved that notion that they almost you
know introduced this like say Zora in
time and took the Nightwatchman out of
the present moment or into an infinite
present moment where he didn't know how
much time had passed and in that gap was
the was the was the bank robbery itself
the time bandits as it were yeah the
yeah and this I think what's also an
undercurrent here that you know the
built environment is also a product of
of codes and of our social contract and
and that fundamentally all of these best
burglars especially these guys that
never got caught they were social
engineers as much as they were anything
else there were people who understood
mining systems they understood fire
codes they understood and in the case of
the Leslie Gang he would just go and
like talk to them like an architect and
often get their plans just handed to
them that he would use against them do
you have a question I'm I was thinking
about the sort of most recent
incarnation of your bank robbers being
sort of
on the Internet and whether you've seen
much overlap between the infiltration of
physical spaces and digital ones that
the social psychology behind Matt yeah
um it's interesting yeah I mean that
question comes up a lot in terms of what
is happening what is Roberto Ruiz
relationship to hacking into digital
bank crime and identity theft but also
what whether burglary so to speak
legally speaking it's not burglary and
so one of the things I wanted to do with
the book was specifically focus on an
analog relationship to architecture so
you would have to physically enter a
space not just you know hack in and take
somebody's passcode or drain their bank
account but it is interesting I think I
think the two things that interest me
there are the extent to which we
spatialize information through metaphors
so that it sounds as if we are hacking
into a computer are you in someone's
bank accounts and is that actually a
useful spatial metaphor to use I think
that that's something that comes out of
basically just the rhetorics of data
space so to speak and whether or not we
can apply burglary as a crime to it and
that as of now we can't so it is not
considered burglary but it is
interesting though that digital crime is
so easy now and draining bank accounts
and ATM skimming and other forms of
instantaneous digital crime that
burglary is way down so in New York City
for example where I live it's down
eighty-one percent I think since the
1980s to the present day I mean which is
in effect that's an endangered crime you
know it doesn't it really doesn't happen
very often and actually jackbacks when
the the individual I mentioned in
Toronto had a pretty interest
interestingly melancholic attitude
towards this which was that when he
started burglarizing burglaring Bergling
you know he felt like he was part of a
community of people who were kind of
almost like urban explorers who were
rethinking the built environment and now
though it's as if he's the and is one of
the reasons where he stopped he's just
like he was he was the he was the Omega
man you know there wasn't there was
nobody else around there's no one else
to talk to about this it felt like a
dying sort of pointless activity and so
he went into the the security field but
so in any case he had the via
it's not burglary and but it will be
interesting to see how and if legal
theory comes around to look at hacking
as some kind of spatialized activity
because at the moment it's not and I
feel like it shouldn't be I mean it's
not actually spatial that's just a
metaphor and the the social engineering
aspect sometimes crosses this line you
know
a lot of people that we Mucha that
mutually know do physical security and
penetration test and and often their
parlor trick when they're at a company
that they're doing work for is they'll
walk up to the nearest desk and start
flipping over mouse pads and keyboards
and like okay well there's there's
persons key there's their password is
written right there and there's this
person's passwords written right here so
often people will use physical means to
get to the virtual means or social
engineering which crosses both of these
fields Mike over here
thank you that's that's a fascinating
way of looking at things all right I'm
interested in the value that people are
putting on that time and space so these
guys in LA clearly put a lot of time and
effort and thought in doing that I don't
know what that costs how they might do
that cost analysis against how much do
they actually take from that Bank after
all that time did it did they break even
was it the social gratification we got
away were there additional crimes
besides the one that they bailed on yeah
that crew may have been part of well I
mean that's a good that's a good it's a
good question it's the because they
haven't been identified it's an it's
impossible to answer many of those but
it is interesting though to look at a
couple things one is the nature of
safe-deposit robberies in general which
is what it was at the in the end they
robbed the safe-deposit boxes
that's is really nebulous and strange
world actually because people will
simultaneously over claim what they have
in a safe deposit box in order to get
insurance on things that aren't actually
there or they will under claim because
they actually have things in the
safe-deposit box but they don't want to
legally admit to it or for that matter
for personal and family reasons they
don't admit that they had something and
so it's actually really difficult to
calculate exactly what is stolen in any
of these cases one detail I I should
mention actually
was that um which is I find strangely
endearing was that they were so good at
tunneling and they were really good at
the city they knew the city from you
know from the down side up but they were
really bad at bank robbing actually so
one of the things that they did that was
funny was that you know if you're
robbing safe-deposit boxes
There is obviously a way to get into
safe deposit boxes either through the
locks themselves or through the hinges
that just allows you to slide the whole
thing out and then do the one above it
and one below it etc but the way they
did it was through brute force prying of
the doors which meant that for everyone
they opened they prevented they
physically blocked themselves from
getting into the one above it to the
right to the left and below which meant
for everyone they robbed there were four
that they couldn't rob so that's a
really bad ratio and it implies that
they were just so excited at what they
knew about the city and what they knew
they could do in the earth but they just
went ahead and did it and and didn't get
away with all the stuff that they could
have gotten but so but yeah that's the
question though you know I mean it's
it's what what is the why do people do
this kind of thing and I think that you
know it often comes up on when when I
talk about the book
that there's a risk of romanticizing
burglars in particular because it's
really fun to talk about but what is the
romance you know because you see it it's
not it doesn't it didn't start with a
burglars guide to the city like you see
it in even just the you know George
Clooney and Ocean's eleven or Cary Grant
and to catch a thief this there or that
ya or James Bond and and whatnot but
that suave you know the figure who who
is who is who can who can walk into any
any bank or enemy lair and and get what
they want what does that romanticization
come from and I guess it my quick answer
to that is that it it feels as if
architecture is and always has been a
three-dimensional puzzle but because of
morals and legal consequences we refused
to look at it that way or at least I you
know speaking again for myself it's
really easy to avoid realizing that
almost as if we live in a world of
three-dimensional Sudoku or a crossword
puzzle or a django puzzle that we that
we can that we can solve differently
burglars come along and they find a
different ways to get from one room to
the next to get from one building to the
next and they reveal that all along
there was this shortcut almost like you
know enter
a code into a Nintendo game and suddenly
having all the powers like they figured
out a way to short-circuit the entire
world and there's something really
strange and magical about that let alone
the kind of appeal of instant riches but
I think that that's one of the reasons
why this kind of thing seems to have
like in a romantic appeal and by way of
coming back to your question is why
people invest so much time in it you
know let's pretend that San Francisco is
a puzzle now let's solve that puzzle
tonight and we can find things using
storm sewer networks and docks and and
waiting for the fog to roll in and
there's all kinds of things we can do
and it's fun and so I think that that's
one of the reasons why people do it not
because they they're gonna end up with
millions of dollars which incidentally
they often can't spend anyway because
they have it all in cash and they'll be
screwed if they do it so because of the
way the cash is regulated controlled and
or notated and in banks so it's a really
dubious and kind of stupid crime to
commit
yeah and we had in our in our other
speaking series there group from Paris
that that broke into kind of historical
buildings and repaired them for the for
the government they repaired they spent
months repairing this clock and then you
know called them up called up the city
one morning and said you know your
clocks that you've that's been broken
for four hundred years now been fixed
and so they would they would kind of
break in to do deeds of good which I
think leads you more to the the part of
the Romanticism and you know they were
doing it to do it but also to unlock the
city in it in a new way okay we have
another question you mentioned urban
explorers briefly the group I was
involved with in Minneapolis at one
point some of my friends broke into a
construction trailer stole the map of
all of the storm sewers for the entire
city
took it to Kinkos scanned it made a
bunch of CDs and then went broke back
into the construction trailer again to
put it back doing this all in like four
hours over the course of the night I
guess my question is like why you know
clearly urban explorers don't have the
moral code of not going into places that
they're not supposed to be so why don't
you think there are more explorers who
are burglars
and or do you think there are explorers
who are burglars and they're just so
good at it that nobody knows about it
it's actually a surprisingly tricky
question because well from if I was a
police officer I would say that many of
those explorers are burglars because of
the intention to do whatever it is they
might be doing down there whether it
might be photographing on public
property they might be engaged in other
forms of activity that might involve you
know whatever it is that they might have
brought along with them they might have
things that can be constituted as
weapons they might have drug
paraphernalia there are many things that
a law-enforcement individual could say
well they are committing burglary
because remember burglary is not theft
but that's it's it's a tricky question
at one point there was going to be an
entire part of the book that was about
urban exploration and it's a
relationship it's conceptual
relationship with burglary but through
speaking with people in the urban
exploration world it just seemed to be
the analogy I kind of used is that it's
almost like and this came up with
lock-picking as well it's like looking
around for heavy metal fans and then
asking them all about what it feels to
be a Satanist or how does it feel to you
know to have no yeah moral moral code
and in terms of religion which in other
words is a ridiculous question to ask
and pigeon holds people based on
something that they do on the expected
illegality of it but so I didn't want to
write the chapter that would look at her
B'nai separation in terms of burglary
because I don't think that a kind of
joyous exploration of publicly funded
infrastructure should necessarily be
criminalized in that way
I do think more people would very easily
and definitely be urban explorers if
there wasn't the perceived legal risk of
doing so so when there is a gate that's
closed the question shouldn't be can we
should we or it amongst the one of the
it it shouldn't necessarily be the first
question to ask whether or not someone
has the legal right to be on the other
side of that door but why is that door
there in the first place like what is
preventing us from performative
ownership of things we fund and and
enjoy as the infrastructure of modern
society so those are tunnels those are
bridges those are the back rooms of
buildings and that kind of thing and so
it's a pretty complex question I think
in terms of the moral aspect of it but I
do think that that's one of the things
you
you see happening as well now is that
urban exploration is being treated more
and more as burglary it's being treated
as a form of pretty aggressive
trespassing and it's being cracked down
upon especially in terms of the notion
that you know we have no idea maybe
these are people from Isis and they're
they're gonna you know they're gonna
pull a you know they're going to blow up
the houses of parliament from the from a
disused subway station and London or you
know I mean just let you know whatever
it might be you know so if people look
at you suspiciously if you photograph
you know police station imagine what
would happen if they found you
underneath that police station with with
with maps to the whole city and so I
think that's the problem is really just
that the infrastructure is not seen as
public space and and there are times are
it that's right and there are times
where that's not right last question so
we have a question from the live chat
and first they wanted to mention that
here in San Francisco thanks everybody's
listening on the livestream or watching
on livestream there's a b-side security
conference at the DNA lounge here in
town and yesterday apparently they
mentioned we're talking about walk pics
and actually included lockpicks in the
badge for the conference so that's I
think still going on right now are
across town but the the question they
want to ask to further the digital
physical comparison beyond ATM skimming
we're wondering if you found any stories
about burglars physically stealing or
removing ATMs and is that another whole
chapter that they could exist it is I
mean again the the funny thing in this
this might sound anticlimactic but is
that depending on where the ATM is it
wouldn't be burglary so you would if you
if you've never go into an architectural
space and if you haven't broken a
clothes or gone under an awning or gone
into any sort of roofed or walled
structure that would be any number of
other things like vandalism and larceny
and and other federal crimes for
stealing monetary instruments but it
wouldn't necessarily be burglary but in
any case yes you do see that kind of
thing yeah entire ATMs get stolen I mean
you see it you see it literally in movie
and TV shows like breaking bad but that
does happen
there of examples including in Europe of
using explosives to blow ATM fronts off
and steal cash or the entire machine the
example I used with the potatoes was a
variant on that in the sense that they
were blowing from the inside out cash
deposit boxes and you can easily do that
to an ATM but you're also seeing in the
hardening of Bank structures as well
you're seeing criminals turn to other
modes of getting cash easier and so why
on earth would you break into the vaults
when you can just rip the ATM off you
know with some chains and a pickup truck
and and get the cash out of it so you
are seeing that the only thing is just
yeah it's just this isn't necessarily
technically a burglary so to just have
finished follow up on that just there's
a range as you talked about from the
start from sort of Darwin Awards
attempts to you know sophisticated
things would you say there's an overall
net kind of evolutionary progress that's
happening or do the same stupid mistakes
how would you characterize the evolution
if it's happening of those burglary
techniques
yeah I guess I'd say that it's you know
I don't know if there's got to be a word
from ecology for this but the as the
excuse me as the as the techniques of
burglary evolved so did the techniques
of defense and so there's a there's a
yes there's a stasis but yeah it's an
arms war between one side and the other
be yeah you do see really sophisticated
things emerging but at the same time
then if somebody then all they all move
to a different type of material that you
can no longer use a cutting torch on or
they all go to a different type of lock
that you can no longer use certain tools
of access for then there's going to move
to something else and so that the line
of evolution will end but the stupidity
doesn't go away yeah and so I think you
mentioned this that that most crimes are
not the Leslie gang building replicas of
banks and in in warehouses they're most
crimes are kind of jackasses grabbing an
opportunity right so this is we're
talking about a rarity of the successful
ones definitely yeah I mean it's the
overwhelming majority are either crimes
of opportunity or ill-considered I mean
just just
a final example because I really like
this story was one where it sounded like
the guy hat you know he he had this
individual in Oregon had a brainwave and
he realized that you know everybody's
targeting banks and financial
institutions but what about a Natural
History Museum you know it's got gold
it's got gemstones it's got all kinds of
really rich mineral wealth and and
they're not exactly expecting you know
Tom Cruise and Mission Impossible to
break in so he had a really great
insight but then what he did was that uh
which is hilarious was that he dressed
up in a ghillie suit and so a ghillie
suit is something that a military sniper
will wear in order to blend in with
plant life and so it makes you look like
a fern or some sort of shrubbery that
you might find on a hillside while
dressed like a plant he robbed a Museum
of rocks and minerals which is possibly
the worst camouflage he could have
chosen and and was arrested inside the
museum and also has a legendary mugshot
because he's so he's still fully dressed
like a plant so yeah you get you get the
good with the bad I guess you could say
yeah well as all speakers I'd like to
give you one of our long out challenge
coins thank you very much and yes thank
you another round of applause for Jeff
please
[Applause]
[Music]